[Musique]
février 2013
j'ai 25 ans je suis étudiant ali ex et
dans le cadre de mon master en relations
publiques je me retrouve à paris dans
une ac une dans une agence de
communication digitale
alors pour vous situer un peu la chose
je me retrouve dans un petit open space
pas plus grand que cette scène ici en
fait l'open 13 est plus ou moins un
tiers de l'espace de cette scène et
j'arrive comme vous pouvez le voir à
l'image derrière moi les gens sont l'un
sur l'autre
la personne juste en face de moi et mon
chef direct et il n'a pas fallu une
semaine avant que je me rends compte que
les gens dans cet open space
communiquent entre eux par messagerie
instantanée messagerie instantanée juste
imaginer et donc à bon matin j'arrive à
mon bureau je suis en train de vaquer à
mes occupations derrière mon ordinateur
pépère et là je vois son ordinateur une
petite icône de notification skype en
haut de mon écran qui arrive est en fait
c'est mon chef juste en face de moi qui
me demande d'aller y chercher un café
j'hallucine le mec est juste en face de
moi et plutôt que de prendre la parole
il m'écrit par skype et donc moi je vais
à paris
les rêves plein la tête je me dis mais
paris c'est là que les pros de la
communication sont je voulais les voir à
l'oeuvre
j'avais vraiment des rêves
professionnels mais non en fait je
déchante complètement tous ceux qui me
proposait là bas dans cette agence la
base c'était vraiment tout ce que je
détestais alors à 25 ans j'ai des rêves
professionnels bien évidemment mais j'ai
aussi des rêves de voyage j'avais encore
jamais quitté l'europe et je passe tout
mon temps libre à lire des témoignages
des récits de voyageurs qui ont voyagé à
travers le monde ont fait le tour du
monde en stop pendant trois ans cinq ans
voire même 10 ans et donc tout ça me
donne des idées
ils m'inspirent énormément et cela
mixait à la frustration qui ce n'est
qu'ils n'aient suite à ce stage et ses
quatre mois cloîtré dans une petite
agence à paris me font donc prendre la
décision qu'à la fin de mon stage quand
j'ai mon diplôme en poche je partirai
moi aussi faire le tour du monde en stop
en commençant par un an en australie et
donc quatre mois plus tard j'arrive
j'arrive avec mon diplôme en poche on
est au mois de juin et donc via le
moment d'annoncer à mes parents que ben
je vais pas aller travailler je vais pas
suivre la vitre av c'est rêver que vous
avez pour moi je pars à 1 en australie
au minimum avec un aller simple je sais
pas du tout quand je reviendrai l'idée
c'est de partir faire le tour du monde
en 3 ans 5 ans 10 ans j'avais aucune
idée et donc pas forcément mes parents
n'étaient pas très chauds le problème
c'est que mon allait pour l'australie d'
était en septembre et pas en juin et
donc je me retrouve avec trois mois
trois mois d'été à passer avec mes
parents chez moi et eux vont tout faire
en sorte en trois mois pour me faire
changer d'avis et donc tous les soirs
pendant pendant ces trois mois d'été et
ma mère venait dans ma chambre la petite
larme à l'oeil
essayer de me faire changer d'avis de
jouer un peu sur l'émotion elle même et
enfin trouve-t-on un vrai job trouve toi
une copine achète une maison achète une
voiture mais non genre démordrai pas il
fallait absolument que je j'aille
voyager soif de curiosité était vraiment
trop intense et donc on arrive fin
septembre il est l'heure de partir en
australie
mon voyage mon départ se fait depuis
paris et mes parents dans leurs grandes
montées décide de m'accompagner jusqu'à
la gare des guillemins
on arrive aux guillemins et là c'est un
moment assez intense qui c'est qui s'est
passé je vois pour la première fois de
ma vie mon père pleurer devant moi ce
que j'ai appris par la suite c'est que à
ce moment là il pensait qu'elle ne le
reverrait plus jamais donc pour compter
pour contextualiser un peu mon père va
d'une famille d'immigrés grecs il arrivé
en belgique à l'âge de 4 ans et dans son
schéma familial quand on quitte son pays
d'origine pour un autre pays
c'est souvent pour ne plus jamais y
revenir et pour s'installer dans ce pays
donc lui était persuadé que j'allais en
australie j'allais trouver une femme là
bas un job et crée ma petite famille et
puis basta quoi bon ils avaient tort je
suis revenu comme vous pouvez le voir
mais donc voilà ça a été assez intense
c'était très très très émouvant de les
voir battre ici pour épauler pour moi
aussi mais je gardais la pêche mon envie
de découvrir le monde était plus grande
que tout est donc j'arrive à melbourne
melbourne qui elle
paradis j'avais des rêves plein la tête
des 40 degrés des filles en bikini des
sables chauds mais j'arrive à melbourne
et là qu'est ce qui se passe c'est la
drache belge nationale qui m'attend
ronde et début octobre et en fait ce que
je ne savais pas c'est que melbourne est
une ville très européenne d'un point de
vue météo et donc le printemps d'être
commencé donc il faisait très venteux il
y avait de la pluie à n'en plus finir
mais encore une fois je garde ma pêche
je me dis mais c'est pas grave
une nouvelle aventure commence et donc
je suis avec mon gros sac à dos de 80
litres sur le dos un plus petit sac à
dos devant tout aussi lourd et depuis le
centre ville de melbourne je commence à
me diriger vers mon premier hôte carole
surfing c'était le seul projet que
j'avais en arrivant en australie ce
thème et trois premières nuits en kite
surfing et donc je marche sous la pluie
la plus australienne avec mes deux sacs
à dos et là quand je me remémore ce
moment c'est vraiment le moment le plus
intense de ma vie encore aujourd'hui
parce que c'est là que j'ai pris
conscience que je revivais quelque chose
ma nouvelle vie commençait à ce moment
là je pouvais devenir surfeurs
professionnels j'aurais pu devenir
fermiers éleveurs de dromadaires dans le
bush australien ou photographes tous
s'ouvraient à moi j'avais plus aucune
limite et c'est vraiment ce sentiment de
nos limites qui m'a envahi et ce moment
là et qui m'a rendu superfreak et cinq
ans plus tard c'est encore le moment je
crois le plus intense de ma vie et donc
je suis à melbourne
les semaines passent je me trouve une
petite colocation et très vite je me
rends compte qu'en fait la vie en
australie c'est très très cher et c'est
certainement pas les quelques 7000 euros
que j'avais économisé durant mes études
qu'ils allaient me permettent de voyager
pendant des années à travers le monde
c'était juste impossible et donc j'ai
commencé à chercher un petit boulot à
trouver à trouver un moyen de gagner de
l'argent
donc j'ai postulé en danse pizzaïolo
j'ai postulé en tant que serveuse de
restaurant mais personne ne voulait de
moi et donc j'ai dû trouver une
alternative
et cette alternative ça a été de
m'isoler pendant plusieurs semaines chez
moi dans ma coloc à melbourne et pendant
plusieurs semaines j'ai tenté d'élaborer
des plans de trouver une stratégie qui
me permettrait de voyager plus longtemps
moins cher voire peut-être même
gratuitement et donc on est en décembre
on se retrouve en décembre 2013 et je
suis avec mon coloc à melbourne et la
j'envoie un mail j'envoie un mail à une
personne qui est administrateur d'une
page facebook
cette page facebook c'est là une page
facebook qui s'appelle était tout
simplement comme la saison est donc
cette personne certainement aux débuts
de facebook en 2007 ou 2010 a créé la
page facebook était en disant que
lui-même elle était qu'ils voulaient
certainement partager son amour pour
l'était que d'autres allaient
certainement je suis et donc au fil des
années il sert tout avec 2 millions
d'abonnés sur sa page était et moi je
contacte cette personne et au moment de
contacter cette personne j'envoie un
mail et je dis à mon coloc de l'époque
martin écoute je pense vraiment que le
mail que j'ai envoyés maintenant risque
de changer ma vie et donc se mêlent
disait ceci c'était bonjour monsieur je
m'appelle windows je suis voyageurs j'ai
étudié les relations publiques et j'ai
fait une spécialisation en réseaux
sociaux ça va plusieurs semaines et mois
que j'observe un peu votre page je vois
que l'engagement n'est plus aussi
flagrant qu'avant et il ya quelques
problèmes de ligne éditoriale je pense
que je pourrais vous amener quelques
conseils pour vous aider à retrouver le
lan trains d'antan et contre toute
attente cette personne me répond
et elle me répond écoute merci pour ton
email j'en reçois des comme les tiens
tous les jours par dizaines mais je ne
sais pas pourquoi le thiam a parlé plus
que puisque les autres ok lançons nous
faisons quelque chose ensemble
on va voir ce que ce que tu peux me
proposer et donc du jour au lendemain je
me retrouve à la tête d'une page
facebook de deux millions d'abonnés
chose qui est énorme d'un point de vue
marketing en 2013 mais ça me suffisait
pas je voulais je voulais venir avec un
projet un peu plus concret plus que
juste une simple page facebook et donc
j'avais l'idée de créer un webzine un
site web dédié aux voyages sur lequel je
posterai des récits de voyages mais
aussi sur lequel d'autres voyageurs
posterai et partageraient le récit de
voyage et donc j'ai contacté certains
blogueurs des blogueurs professionnels
ou des blogueurs amateurs qui avaient
chacun leur blog de leur côté et je leur
ai proposé de rejoindre ce collectif qui
s'appellerait partir en été comme le nom
du webzine pour s'associer à la page
facebook et d'écrire pour ce webzine
donc et en échange de leurs articles
verraient leurs articles partagés sur la
page facebook à 2 millions d'abonnés ce
qui potentiellement générer un trafic
sur leurs blogs personnels et donc tout
le monde était content j'ai réussi à
à générer un collectif de 30 blogueurs
qui écrivait pour le webzine le webzine
se lancent tout tout est parfait la vie
est belle et deux jours plus tard deux
jours seulement après le lancement de ce
webzine je suis contacté par alex alex
qui est le fondateur de du plus gros
site de voyages francophones qui
s'appelle voyager loin et alex me dis
que ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'il a
suivi l'évolution depuis plus ou moins
que j'ai j'ai collaboré avec le gars de
la page était et donc il me propose tout
simplement de rejoindre son équipe et de
venir travailler avec lui et il s'avère
que en parallèle de sa ma relation
personnelle avec l'administrateur la
page est et à l'est en dégringolade ce
monsieur n était pas très professionnel
il avait il avait très peu d'ambition et
il voulait pas vraiment écouté mais
conseille donc ça match est pas tout
simplement
et donc j'ai pris mon équipe de 30
blogueurs et tous ensemble on a été
rejoindre alex et son site voyager loin
et donc du jour au lendemain pareil je
me retrouve avec cette petite carte de
visite
yoann aux photographes blogueurs et et
faudrait rédacteur pour voyager loin sur
un site donc de 2 millions de pardon de
2 millions de visites par mois et il
avait cinq cent mille abonnés sur
facebook est donc là on se retrouve en
janvier janvier 2014
j'ai envie enfin de quitter melbourne de
partir de voir le pays et j'étais
toujours dans mon idée un peu de tours
du monde en auto-stop
donc j'avais envie d'aller à ce qui est
à 4000 km de melbourne donc toujours
dans ce trip en auto stop je me dis moi
je le tente et en stop pourquoi pas donc
je me renseigne je vois que la le trajet
prendrait plus ou moins une semaine ça
comprenez une traversée du désert ça
comprenez pas mal de choses donc on peut
en fils modèle je préviens quand même ma
mère qui est toujours en belgique jeudi
écoute voilà demain je pars pour poste
et j'en aurais pour une semaine dans le
désert soit fun à bientôt
et ben voilà évidemment maman maman
poule me dit il est hors de question que
tu fasses ça j'ai vu qu'il ya un train
qui va de melbourne apple c'est un train
de trois jours trois nuits je te paye le
billet de train mais est hors de
question que tu fasses une traversée du
désert en stop au moins tu seras sain et
sauf et moi de monde pour à vue n'était
pas du tout question de ma mère
interviennent financièrement dans ce
projet ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
l'idéologie du voyage mais une idée a
germé je suis dit tiens c'est vrai que
ce petit voyage en train ça a l'air
intéressant
pourquoi pas ça me faisait un peu penser
au transsibérien qui est un voyage que
j'ai toujours voulu faire
trois jours trois nuits dans un tram
pourquoi pas sauf que j'avais pas les
moyens de me payer ce billet de train et
donc j'ai contacté la compagnie train et
je leur ai proposé un deal qui était ben
voila je m'appelle lui and loss je suis
rédacteurs et photographes pour le plus
gros site de voyages francophone est ce
que ça vous intéresse de collaborer vous
m'offrez le billet de train et en
échange j'ai écrit un article sur vous
sur sur mon site et ça vous ferait de la
visibilité et de la publicité gratuite
et là contre toute attente ils me
répondent ils me disent mais bien sûr
vous êtes le bienvenu
on va vous accueillir en première classe
on va vous mettre une cabine
rien que pour vous et on vous offre
accès au restaurant gastronomique
package à 7000 $ jeudi mais huawei donc
j'hallucine
bon je vais dans le train expérience
fabuleuse j'arrive à puff
et là il ya une seconde activité que
j'ai vraiment envie de faire c'est aller
observer les grands requins blancs dans
leur milieu naturel
donc on est dans une cage ça coûte assez
cher c'était 500 dollars australiens et
je n'avais pas encore les moyens de le
payer non plus donc pareil j'envoie un
mail similaire le même deal est là aussi
me bien sûr vous êtes le bienvenu on va
prendre en charge ceux ci tant que vous
écrivez un article sur voyager loin
et donc là vraiment je prends conscience
de la puissance de voyager loin et des
réseaux sociaux en général est donc venu
mais est-ce qu'il suffit juste d'envoyer
des mails pour vraiment recevoir tous
gratuitement est-ce que c'est aussi
simple que ça et donc j'ai passé le
reste de mon séjour en australie en
faisant de 10 l'an deal comme ça je
waquet jeu vaquer à mes occupations
j'avais des activités gratuites ou en
tout cas pas cher avec des ristournes
vraiment en profitant de la vie et en
parallèle de tout ça ça me permettait de
créer du contenu unique est assez
incroyable pour mon compte instagram
personnel sur lequel j'avais à peine une
centaine d'abonnés quand je suis quand
je suis arrivé en australie et donc je
postais des photos tous les jours sans
vraiment aucune perspective d'avenir
puis un jour je me suis réveillé m et je
me réveille avec 5000 abonnés sur mon
compte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je découvre
que le national geographic ar post est
une de mes photos
une meute de mes photos d'australie et
là ça a été immédiat donc je passe 200
abonnés à 5000 abonnés en une nuit et à
partir de là tout s'enchaîne des
demandes d'interview dans tous les sens
des sites du monde entier qui veulent
utiliser
photo d compte instagram qui continue à
poster mes photos le compte officiel de
l'australie plainte conte de médias
comme buzzfeed mashable daily mail
hélas à partir de ce moment là ça a été
vraiment crescendo et je vois mes
abonnés instagram monté en flèche et ça
ne s'est plus jamais arrêté donc j'ai
continué mon voyage en australie
de la sorte en faisant des deals grâce à
voyager loin et en postant des photos
sur mon compte instagram est donc à la
fin de mon année en australie on est en
septembre 2014
je quitte le pays avec 25 mille abonnés
et jeudi maintien jeu maintenant je vais
aller vendre tout ce qui se passe en
nouvelle zélande et donc j'arrive dans
ce pays merveilleux pays et je fais un
gros trip 2 3 - avec un ami ils ont
traversé tout le pays les deux îles
pendant trois mois c'est fabuleux et on
arrive dans un petit village perdu dans
les montagnes à côté dans lac sublime
wanaka et là c'est le coup de foudre
immédiat je me dis mais je veux vivre là
ça a l'air trop beau c'est vraiment là
que j'ai envie de poser enfin mes
valises prend le temps de souffler
prendre le temps de rien faire aussi et
de me concentrer un peu sur ma carrière
de photographe qui commençait un peu à
décoller et donc pareil je contacter
l'office du tourisme de wanaka mais pour
la première fois de ma vie je la
contacter en mon nom propre et plus du
tout en tant que photographe ou
rédacteurs pour voyager loin
et donc je leur propose un deal qui
consiste en voilà je m'appelle windows
je suis photographe
j'ai cinquante mille abonnés sur
instagram j'aimerais beaucoup vivre ici
est ce que vous pourriez prendre en
charge mon hébergement pendant trois
mois et en échange je me fais
ambassadeur digitale de votre région et
je poste du contenu sur instagram et je
promouvoir votre région qui n'est encore
pas très connu et pareil ils acceptent
ils me disent mais oui bien sûr on va
vous offrir on vous offre l'hébergement
et donc il me fera un petit studio très
petit mais tout ce que tout ce dont
j'avais besoin
donc les trois mois deviennent sept mois
et finalement je passe sept mois à
wanaka dans le plus bel endroit de
nouvelle zélande un des plus beaux
endroits au monde selon moi et tout ça
m'a permis non seulement de découvrir
une nouvelle passion qui aiment les
grands espaces les montagnes la
randonnée mais aussi d'affiner mon style
photos de me créer une vraie identité
par rapport à vos photos que je faisais
un nouvel an et que je ne faisais pas en
australie mais aussi de passer beaucoup
de temps avec d'autres photographes ou
des amateurs de randonnées et de nature
comme moi et donc ça m'a permis de créer
beaucoup de contacts d'avoir un style
beaucoup plus affinée sans instagram et
mon nom était associé de
plus en plus avec ce style de photos de
grands espaces et de paysages et donc
une fois que j'étais à wanaka et que
j'ai passés donc la barre des cent mille
abonnés sur instagram je voyais
également mes premiers clients arrivent
et j'avais des demandes de contrats
rémunérés qui arrivait et plus ou moins
en mars 2015 j'ai pris la décision de
passer à temps plein en tant que
photographe et de tenter ma chance en
disant mais voilà on va voir ce qui
arrivera peut-être que ça marchera pas
mais au moins ici j'ai assez de contrats
qui me permettent de ne vivre plus que
de ça et donc je finis mais mon année en
nouvelle-zélande on est en septembre
2015 ça fait deux ans que j'ai quitté la
belgique il est je me dis maintien il
est peut-être temps pour moi maintenant
de rentrer en belgique de revoir du pays
mes amis ma famille me manque
allons voir ce qui s'y passe peut-être
que ça va être un échec peut être que
tout va se tasser ou au contraire que ça
va continuer au mieux et donc je rentre
en belgique en octobre 2015
et là en fait grosse surprise tous
continuent à s'enchaîner des offices du
tourisme du monde entier continuent à me
contacter et la jordanie
le canada la norvège et tous me propose
de venir dans leur pays afin de faire la
promotion de leur région sur instagram
est donc non seulement ils m'invitent
gratuitement mais en plus de ça il me
rémunère pour la création de contenu et
pour la publicité que je pouvais leur
apporter sur les réseaux sociaux est
donc aujourd'hui moi je suis devenu
photographe professionnel non seulement
je collabore avec des eaux-vives
tourisme ou des dés à des acteurs du
monde du voyage mais je collabore aussi
avec des marques je suis notamment
ambassadeur pour une marque de voiture
depuis deux ans maintenant
on a été faire un gros tour d'europe
l'an passé à travers à donc à travers
l'europe lui pendant cinq mois hélas ici
je rentre tout juste de norvège
justement où j'ai donné un atelier photo
pendant encore une semaine un groupe de
huit personnes qui voulaient découvrir
la norvège les îles lofoten qui selon
moi sont c'est ma région préférée au
monde mais non seulement les voir mais
aussi apprendre les bases de la photo et
comment vraiment shooter sur place et
donc voilà ça fait deux ans et demi que
je fais ça que je peux vivre de ma
passion mes deux passions qui sont à
savoir le voyage et la photo est alors
ce que je voulais vraiment partager avec
vous aujourd'hui c'est finalement quand
je regarde ce parcours les cinq ans qui
viennent de se passer
il ya vraiment une chose je pense qui en
ressort c'est quand je me rends je me
remémore ce qui s'est passé en australie
et que
j'ai approché cet administrateur de la
page facebook je pense que le mot clé
c'est l'audace et c'est vraiment ce
sentiment que j'ai envie de partager
avec vous c'est essayer vous avez vous
n'avez absolument rien à perdre j'avais
peut-être une chance sur dix que cette
personne me répond d'une chance sur cent
je savais absolument pas ce qui allait
advenir j'avais aucune perspective
d'avenir c'est j'ai juste lâché jeter un
mail dans l'océan sans vraiment savoir
ce qui allait advenir en retour et cette
personne m'a répondu j'appelle ça ma
chance sur 10 ou sur chaussures 100 mais
allait arriver
pareil quand j'ai contacté la compagnie
train ou l'office du tourisme moana
qu'il sait j'avais absolument rien à
perdre
j'avais juste un rêve que ça aboutisse
et donc j'ai tenté ma chance et je pense
que c'est ça le plus important
aujourd'hui c'est que si vous avez des
rêves
si vous avez des projets qui vous semble
irréalisable ou très difficile à
atteindre mais tentez votre chance il
suffit juste peut-être d'envoyer un mail
peut-être de rencontrer la bonne
personne et ces personnes vont peut-être
vous aider à aboutir à bref merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
keith huff